hey friends its January 27th I'm chasity
with Aberdeen and it's the best day ever
cuz it's canine Friday here your top
five stories of the week first up three
new Xbox one backwards compatible games
arrived this week for a total of fifteen
this month the xbox one's backwards
compatibility catalog expanded this week
with the addition of Alice madness
Returns rocket knight and shadows of the
damned if you already own these games
for xbox 360 they should show up
automatically in your xbox one game
library if not you can buy them on your
console or an xbox com Microsoft has now
added 15 titles to the catalog this
month other recent additions include
battlefield 3 and battlefield bad
company 2 there are more than 300 xbox
360 games playable on Xbox one via
backwards compatibility are there any
other 360 games you still want to play
on the xbox one tell us in the comments
next up Nintendo switch pro controller
sold out almost immediately on amazon
and at gamestop gamestop opened
pre-orders for the nintendo switch pro
controller today and it looks like the
store like amazon earlier in the week
sold out of units almost immediately
GameStop's news release announcing
availability when out at ten fifty seven
a.m. eastern time it looks like stock
sold out in a matter of minutes though
you can get one if you pay more for a
bundle the pad remains unavailable on
Amazon where stock sold out in 30
minutes earlier this week it doesn't
appear to have been made available yet
through other retailers though it could
still happen between now and launch the
pro controller features offset analog
sticks similar to that of an Xbox
controller along with motion controls
switches HD Rumble technology and the
ability to read amiibo figures it's
charged with a USBC cable that comes
included next Microsoft removed snap
mode from the Xbox one here's why the
newest xbox one update removes the
consoles multitasking features snap this
was discovered on Monday when the update
started to roll out and was confirmed by
xbox engineering lead Mike ibarra riding
on Twitter ibarra explained that snap
was removed in an effort to improve
multitask
King reduce memory use improve overall
speed and free up resources going
forward for bigger things Microsoft's
decision to back away from snap is not a
total surprise as a November 2016 report
said the company was looking to kill the
feature snap style functionality hasn't
been removed entirely though as you can
enable a new achievement overlay that
lets you track your progress the update
that removes snap is currently available
for some xbox insiders and will go live
for everyone in the spring the overall
goal for the update is to simplify the
UI and improve overall performance
according to Microsoft next up we got a
new Robin gameplay trailer for injustice
to in the official gameplay trailer we
see that Robin makes liberal use of his
sword his special Batarang seemed to
allow him to juggle enemies and teleport
as for other characters another round
boss ed boon said there will be somewhat
obscure characters on the game's roster
the first injustice game covered all the
high points as it relates to the
well-known DC characters with a sequel
diving deeper into some new ones you may
not know as much about he also teased
that there is a good chance another
round will release third-party
characters as DLC for injustice too he
said these were very popular in Mortal
Kombat X so nether realm is doing it
again overall injustice to will have the
largest roster for another realm game
both in terms of on disk and DLC
characters and finally destiny addresses
crucible balance issues in an update
coming next month Bungie has provided an
overview of what to expect from a
forthcoming destiny update the focus of
which is on crucible balancing update
2.5 point 0 point2 does not yet have
patch notes but senior designer Josh
Hamrick did share some of the goals
Bungie has for it sandbox and crucible
designers have been investigating and
updating the competitive ecosystem and
I'm proud to say that we are getting
very close he said in a blog post
through experimentation and nearly daily
battles to the digital death we have
begun to hone in on a set of changes
that we believe freshens things up a
total of five goals are listed such as
providing alternatives and counters for
shotguns and making adjustments to
special weapon ammo check out the rest
at gamespot.com the new update is slated
to
arrived in mid-february and that's our
top five of the week I'm chastity and
this is Daisy and you can find me over
on gamespot universe Jess will be back
next week gamespot universe is our
channel for all things entertainment
like anime wrestling movies TV so come
check it out and I'll see you next time
[Music]